[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du
7-8 europe le magazine européen de la
rédaction de tv 78 au programme de ce
numéro la réhabilitation des murs à
pêches de montreuil en seine saint denis
un site historique est atypique qui
bénéficient des fonds européens pour
retrouver un avenir et permettre à
l'agriculture de se réinstaller en plein
coeur d'une zone urbaine
un projet ambitieux tout comme celui
d'une start-up francilienne qui
développe des radiateurs ultra moderne
ils produisent de la chaleur grâce aux
calculs informatiques c'est à découvrir
dans quelques instants
l'invité politique de cette émission et
patrick le hyaric député européen depuis
2009 il est troisième sur la liste du
parti communiste français pour les
prochaines élections européennes nous
évoquons avec lui l'ambition de son
parti placé très bas pour le moment dans
les sondages et du programme qu'il
souhaite défendre pour cette campagne
est donc tenté de convaincre les
électeurs
[Musique]
enfermé et bordée par la route ils sont
presque invisibles aujourd'hui pourtant
il représente une partie du patrimoine
historique de la ville de montreuil les
murs à pêches retrouvent peu à peu une
vie normale après avoir été oubliés
pendant 50 ans des pouvoirs publics et
des habitants est divers projets sont
actuellement financés pour réinvestir
les lieux et protéger la biodiversité
locale l'union européenne fait partie
des financeurs de ce vaste programme
reportage sur ce site original mémoire
de l'industrie horticole franciliennes
et des murs blancs plus ou moins
défraîchi et de la verdure un peu
partout qui pourrait croire qu'ici à
montreuil en région parisienne du 17e au
19e siècle se trouvaient des arbres
fruitiers sur des kilomètres pourtant
jusque dans les années 70-80 pêches
pommes et poires étaient encore présents
sur ce site de 34 hectares ses murs
servait effectivement à la coupe et
levant sur le plateau à créer un micro
climat propice à la culture des fruits
et donc on avait des arbres plantés au
pied et qui était pas lisse et du coup
sûr sur le mur
la croissance du rail et la pression
foncière pousseront les derniers
producteurs à quitter les lieux
presque abandonnée depuis les murs à
pêches sont revenus récemment un enjeu
patrimonial et environnementale pour les
politiques publiques pour l'europe aussi
qui soutient financièrement un projet de
sentier des biodiversité le cheminement
en fait public qui s'intègre dans tout
le réseau de santé la biodiversité
passera ici et se prolongera au fond de
la parcelle et l'idée de retravailler
l'introduction de végétaux de favoriser
les passages de faune de travailler sur
la fleur francilienne et et de voilà de
reconquérir le site renaturation d'un
cours d'eau des pollutions encore
activités agricoles associations et
municipalité tente aujourd'hui de
travailler ensemble pour redonner vie à
ce lieu historique
aujourd'hui les trois cartes de cet
espace se trouve
en friche abandonné et même je dois le
dire avec un peu de peine a servi de
dépotoir
parce que nous parlerons de la pollution
de ce lieu a servi de dépotoir pendant
de très longues années le sens profond
de ce projet est de restituer ce lieu
aux montreuillois emblème de montreuil
les murs à pêches et s'est doucement de
retrouver leur place au milieu d'un
coeur urbain encore égoïste et on va
poursuivre cette émission avec un autre
projet qui profite des fonds européens
et qui s'inscrit dans cette ambition
environnementale quentin lawrence
bonsoir bonjour vous êtes responsable
des relations publiques pour la société
car nos computing une société basée à
montrouge dans les hauts de seine et qui
développe depuis des années désormais un
projet assez ambitieux presque
révolutionnaire puisque vous produisez
un radiateur écologique est pour le
moins original puisqu'on peut le nommer
ainsi un radiateur calculateur
ordinateur vous allez nous nous préciser
ça en résumé c'est un outil qui exploite
la chaleur émise par le calcul
informatique pour chauffer les habitats
c'est ça c'est bien résumé il faut
d'abord comprendre que les data center
qui sont des espèces de grandes usines
du numérique consomme énormément
d'énergie d'électricité pour alimenter
les serveurs informatiques mais aussi la
refroidir puisqu'on en a tous fait
l'expérience
quand on utilise son ordinateur de la
chaleur est dégagé et quand on parle de
calcul à haute performance la chaleur
dégagée représentent des la chaleur
incroyablement élevé donc arnaud a été
créé en 2010 justement avec comme idée
de base de valoriser la chaleur perdue
des serveurs informatiques
au lieu de tout concentrer te concentrer
tous les microprocesseurs les serveurs
informatiques dans un seul lieu
on a décidé d'apporter la capacité de
calcul directement là où on a besoin de
chaleur en visuellement ça se passe
comment cesser en fait s'est insérée
dans le radiateur c'est ça les
microprocesseurs et la chaleur permet de
chauffer l'habitat alors le
le projet est très très simple vous avez
un radiateur qui ressemble presque à un
radiateur normale dans lequel au lieu
d'avoir des résistances électriques qui
chauffe
vous avez des micro processeurs
informatiques le radiateur et reliés à
la fibre plus l'usager a besoin de
chaleur et plus nous lui envoyons de
calcul par la fibre est donc plus les
microprocesseurs montant fréquence et
dégagent de la chaleur
j'allais vous demander justement comment
comment ça marche concrètement c'est
vous qui fait l'intermédiaire entre les
entreprises et on va dire le particulier
et son chauffage exactement lokola le on
a deux types de clients chez carnot d'un
côté des clients de calcul qui sont des
grandes banques des laboratoires de
recherche des studios d'animation 3d et
de l'autre côté des clients de chauffage
il faut faire l'interface comme vous le
dites entre les deux et donc nous on a
créé notamment une plateforme logicielle
qui permet d'un côté de recevoir des
calculs et de l'autre de les distribuer
là où existent des besoins de chaleur
j'ai évoqué le volet environnemental en
introduction mais c'est vrai qu'il ya ce
volet écologique très important puisque
au lieu de perdre ses de chaleur dans
les data center vous voulez vous
l'exploiter donc c'est aussi bon pour la
planète géré même un petit peu plus loin
jusqu'ici on avait trois sources
d'énergie une qui alimente l datacenter
une qu'il refroidisse est et une
dernière qui chauffent les bâtiments
aujourd'hui grâce à la technologie
carnot vous n'avez plus qu'une source
d'énergie qui chauffent les bâtiments
qui produit des calculs et on a supprimé
la fonction de refroidissement et donc
on a une vertu environnementale qui est
évidente et formule magique ça n'a pas
de coût pour le particulier qui en
profitent expliquez nous comment on
commet du coup ça commence et rentable
pour vous du coup la faire puisque le
particulier ne paient pas ou se voir
rembourser ses frais en arrière de
chauffage alors on travaille pas
directement avec les particuliers je
préfère le dire pour ceux qui nous
regardent
on travaille par l'intermédiaire de
bailleurs sociaux par l'intégrateur
d'entreprise pour des bureaux le
le client consent un investissement au
départ qui est certes un petit peu plus
élevé qu'un une solution de chauffage
classique mais par la suite plus aucun
frais ne lui est imputé on rembourse les
factures d'électricité on assure la
maintenance gratuitement pendant toute
la durée du contrat et on remplace les
machines à échéances régulières pour que
nous gardions une capacité de calcul
efficiente puisqu'il faut pas oublier
que carnot ne se rémunère pas sur le
chauffage mais se rémunère sur le calcul
informatique donc en vendant de calcul
reprise exactement en vendant du calcul
informatique par exemple pour des
grandes banques qui ont besoin de faire
des simulations des analyses de risque
est bien c'est de cette manière là
construit muller aujourd'hui combien
d'appartements de maisons sont équipées
de ce chauffage alors aujourd'hui on a
1000 unités de déployer en france on
commence à vraiment sentir que les
choses s'accélèrent on a mis du temps
avant de faire reconnaître cette
technologie comme une technologie et
écologique ça peut paraître un peu
paradoxal mais on a aussi quelques
lourdeurs administratives parfois au
delà desquels il faut aller on a 1000
unités et les prévisions pour 2019 2020
sont assez encourageantes alors vous
bénéficiez on le disait des des fonds
européens
près de cinq cent mille euros 480000
euros pour vous aider je suppose dans la
recherche et le développement
quel est l'objectif quand on profite des
fonds européens est ce que aussi
peut-être c'est de bénéficier des
marchés du vieux continent les autres
pays alors je dirais qu'il ya deux
volets principaux il ya l'aspect d'abord
recherche et développement qui est le
plus important pour nous donc ça pour
nous l approche des élections
européennes
l'europe c'est aussi ça c'est du très
concret c'est un soutien économique à
une entreprise innovante
je veux dire que carnot et le premier
dans le monde à faire ce chauffage un
peu innovant donc l'europe a cru en ce
projet là nous a soutenu la région ile
de france aussi donc nous on arrive
avec un beau projet qui est soutenue qui
donc on a un appui qui nous permet de
nous de vraiment faire avancer nos
technologies qui sont des technologies
de pointe des technologies de rupture on
entend parfois parler de disruption on
est exactement là dedans donc l'europe
nous est d'abord sur la partie recherche
et développement et puis elle nous aide
aussi sur la partie marché on est allé
récemment au japon découvrir un nouveau
marché dans le cadre d'un partenariat ça
c'est encore l'union européenne qui nous
permet donc on a vraiment une confiance
de la part de l'europe qui nous permet
de faire des choses qu'on n'aurait
jamais fait tout simplement par exemple
fiabiliser nos radiateurs sur la
fabrication le marquage ce et oeufs etc
la plateforme de distribution des
calculs dont je parlais et puis on a mis
un pied aussi c'était le cadre du
justement du feder le fonds dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure
justement pour le bâtiment intelligent
et carnot vous avez compris une fois
qu'on a mis de l'informatique dans le
bâtiment on a un nouveau métier qui se
créent et donc on a des pistes
potentielles très très riches merci
quentin l'organisme est revenu sur notre
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
responsable des relations publiques pour
carnot computing on poursuit cette
émission parlement européen à présent de
strasbourg pour l'interview politique du
mois notre invité est patrick le hyaric
eurodéputés communistes élus au
parlement depuis 2009 et candidat sur la
liste du pcf pour les élections du mois
de mai prochain
[Musique]
et nous sommes donc avec patrick le
hyaric bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes député
européen depuis 2009 vice-président
parlement européen du groupe européen de
la gauche unitaire européenne gauche
verte nordique director aussi du journal
l'humanité est donc candidat pour votre
réélection ici au parlement européen
vous êtes en troisième position sur la
liste du parti communiste français
précision pour ces élections
contrairement à il ya cinq ans votre
partie par seul pari risqué puisque
aujourd'hui les sondages vous place en
dessous de la barre des 5% donc dans la
possibilité d'avoir des des
parlementaires européens est ce qu'on
peut imaginer le 26 mai prochain un
parlement sans élu communiste français
ben non on ne peut pas imaginer les
parlementaires communistes ont toujours
été présents au parlement européen ils
ont tous ils ont toujours joué un rôle
extrêmement utile au service des
populations des vues et des salariés en
général
par conséquent rien n'est joué il reste
plusieurs semaines aujourd'hui avant que
les électrices et les électeurs ne se
prononce pour rappel en 2014 vous
faisiez partie de ce qu'on appelait
alors le front de gauche
vous aviez rassemblé un peu plus de 6%
des voix en france aujourd'hui la gauche
paraît presque pouvoir disparaître du
paysage politique européen et puis
français et pourtant tant de divisions
tant de partis qui prennent leur liste
pourquoi c'est paradoxal c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faudrait se se
rassembler pour pouvoir continuer à
exister politiquement sûr mais ce n'est
pas faute d'avoir essayé beaucoup
d'efforts on a été fait de la part de
notre lise la part de ian brossât de la
part du parti communiste pour qu'on
aboutisse à une liste
unitaire de la gauche de transformation
sociale écologiste que ça se fasse pas
c'est ce qui vient
concrètement selon vous puisque vous
êtes un habitué des lieux jeudi avec vos
collègues je ne sais pas puis je ne veux
pas très rentrer dans cette je fais pas
une émission avec vous pour faire de la
politique politicienne non mais
justement là vous parlez du quelques
comme on l'a fait à bfm donc si vous
voulez on va passer justement pas mal et
tu sais ce qui préoccupe les gens
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est ce que
dans le projet du parti communiste pour
l'europe ne correspond pas par exemple
au projet de la france un sou mais je
sais pas il faut leur demander
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas mon problème
mais ces gens veulent une responsable
aujourd'hui il a laissé lui aujourd'hui
la situation elle est ainsi il est bien
malheureux qu'elle soit ainsi au moment
où des forces d'extrême droite sont en
train de envahir l'ensemble de l'union
européenne
voir le monde je le déplore et je le
regrette mais mettre un bulletin de vote
pour peser en faveur de l'unité
ce sera voté aussi pour la liste de ian
brossât est-ce que l'urgence climatique
c'est un sujet qui intéresse votre liste
pour les élections à venir mais ce n'est
pas que ça nous intéresse c'est que nous
sommes des combattants de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
des combattants du respect de la
biodiversité de l'amélioration de la
biodiversité c'est une
c'est une question désormais de premier
plan avec un certain nombre d'autres
enjeux mais celle-ci est une question de
vie et de mort à terme et il n'y avait
pas moyen là dessus par exemple de
trouver un terrain d'entente le gilet
vert je ne sais pas il a été proposée à
chacune et chacun les gens ils ont
refusé ce n'est pas de ma faute vous
leur demanderont comment vous allez
convaincre les électeurs qui pour
l'instant semble pas favorable à voter
pour vous puisque je lisais les sondages
sont pas très bon on dirait c'est que
des sondages mais comment vous allez
convaincre les élus ya donc si vous
donnez des lecteurs qui ne se sont pas
décidées qui ne savent même pas encore
révélé leur dialogue oil qui ne savent
même pas encore qu'il ya des élections
européennes qui ne savent pas que chaque
voix va compter pour élire un
parlementaire européen puisque nous
allons voter sur des listes nationales à
la proportionnelle et qui ne savent pas
beaucoup d'entre eux que avoir des
députés ici au parlement européen
c'est utile pour eux parce que par
exemple je prends un cas
une question que j'ai soulevé il y a
maintenant plusieurs mois on est en
train d'appliquer dans notre pays un
budget national qui dépendent impact
budgétaire européen qui n'est même plus
juridiquement valide aujourd'hui puisque
il aurait fallu que dans le courant du
mois de décembre le parlement européen
valide ce pacte budgétaire puisqu'il
arrive au terme aujourd'hui il y a le
conseil et la commission mais le
parlement du seul sait le budget l'union
européenne 2021 je n'ai pas le budget de
l'union c'est grâce à cet impact
budgétaire européen qui vise à contrôler
chacun des budgets nationale et c'est au
nom de ce pacte budgétaire qu'on réduit
les sags lambic qu'on est en train de
privatiser
aéroports de paris angie et la française
des jeux prétendument pour réduire la
dette
quels seront les autres axes de campagne
justement puisque vous parlez du valais
par les divers jeux que posent les gens
par exemple le pouvoir d'achat la
question des salaires
aujourd'hui est une question qui est
posée dans l'ensemble de l'union
européenne le on prêt sur les salaires
même dans des pays comme le nôtre comme
au luxembourg qui avons des meilleurs
salaires minima que les portugais que
les espagnols aient encore mieux le
meilleur et puis bien évidemment
malheureusement que le
la pologne où le ou la roumanie ou la
bulgarie
la question de la rémunération du
travail pour tous les salariés de
l'union européenne elle est posée et
donc ça pose la question de la
répartition des richesses et de temps en
temps ça pose la question de créer des
mécanismes aujourd'hui où on augmente
partout les rémunérations du travail et
pourtant dans beaucoup de ces pays c'est
la droite voire l'extrême droite qui est
en tête comment vous l'expliquez même en
france que ce soit leur assemblée c'est
un certain mouvement voici par ses idées
à vous qui s'est traduit c'est un
mouvement mondial qui est à l'oeuvre
aujourd'hui une contre révolution
conservatrice qui va jusqu'à ce que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui on est au delà
de reagan aujourd'hui puisque c'est
monsieur tron c'est monsieur erdogan
c'est des forces d'extrême droite en
hongrie ou de droite extrême en hongrie
d'extrême droite en alliance en italie
et la montée par tous parce que les gens
ils se considèrent comme dos au mur qui
se considère comme non défendu
aujourd'hui et ils veulent donner un
coup de pied peut-être mais il constate
aussi les divisions à gauche
peut-être aussi invraisemblable le mans
que les divisions à gauche ne l'aide pas
la mobilisation l'actualité c'est aussi
évidemment le brésil qui n'en finit pas
les européens ont accepté récemment de
repousser la date effective pour le
moment jusqu'au 12 avril il y à un
accord au parlement britannique ce sera
jusqu'au 22 mai sur sur l'accord conclu
en novembre dernier
c'est très compliqué très confus ce
sujet quels commentaires vous en tirez
vous de ce break 6 2 ce qui se passe
depuis deux trois ans un bac d'abord
ceux qui vont en souffrir ce sont
ceux qui n'ont pas de travail ceux qui
ont des salaires extrêmement bas ceux
qui sont les salariés les seuls qui vont
en profiter
dans le cas d'une concurrence est une
europe de l'argent aujourd'hui ce seront
les grandes multinationales et la city
de londres et c'est ça tout le débat
même le débat à l'intérieur du parti
le conservateur au royaume uni il est
celui là qui servira le mieux la city
c'est à dire on utilise les forces vives
du pays les travailleurs les
travailleuses les plus en difficulté
comme certes comme une opération dans le
cadre d'une opération qui servira le
plus puissant et c'est dans ce contexte
du bric site que emmanuel macron s'est
adressé aux européens début mars dans
une dans une lettre il a notamment s qui
sait plusieurs idées et celles d'un
bouclier social social européen est ce
que ça ça va dans le sens dont vous
parliez sur le fond pour ces élections
un bouclier social européen qui viserait
un peu plus protégé justement les s'il
voulait faire un principalement les
européens de l'est s'il voudrait faire
un si vous voulez faire un bouclier
social européen
j'imagine qu'il augmenterait le smic en
france et qu'il emmènerait pas le
mouvement social aujourd'hui dans les
cordes comme il le fait j'imagine qu'il
lutterait contre la précarité du travail
et qui créerait les conditions pour que
chaque travailleur précaire et un
contrat à durée était terminée j'imagine
qu'il améliorait le système de
protection sociale j'imagine qu'ils ne
voudraient pas reculer l'âge de la
retraite
et pendant ce temps là dessus mais ya
pas de croire ou pas croire est de bonne
foi ou pas de bonne foi
ce sont des petits politiciens de bas
étage qui écrivent des lettres parce que
ils n'ont sans doute que ça à faire mais
nous et les gens doivent juger
uniquement sur les actes et les ac ne
plaisent pas ne plaident pas en leur
faveur
le président de la république a
également évoqué dans cette lettre une
remise à plat de l'espace schengen c'est
justement le sujet de notre pasty
consacré à l'histoire de l'europe on se
plonge ce mois ci il ya 24 ans le 26
mars 1995 pour l'entrée en vigueur de
l'espace schengen justement avec
philippe le guen coordinateur pour le
parlement européen de la maison
jean monnet située dans les yvelines
s'est inspiré du benelux savait que en
belgique pays bas et luxembourg depuis
très longtemps il avait supprimé les
créent les contrôles aux frontières à
l'intérieur de leurs espaces du benelux
et donc tout en ayant des monnaies
différentes en ayant des gouvernements
différents mais il n'y avait plus de
contrôle aux frontières
donc on s'est inspiré de cela pour
l'étendre à au pays de l'époque membre
donc ça va être les accords les premiers
accords ont été signés par les premiers
pays et puis on avait convenu en effet
qu'il faudrait une période de dix ans
pour que ça s'adapte notamment qu'on
supprime effectivement tout le système
des des douanes et aussi des taxes aux
frontières puisque la douane c'est un
c'est une police financière qui est là
pour vérifier que les taxes sont bien
payés par par les importateurs les
exportateurs bon donc il y avait tout un
tas de choses à mettre en oeuvre
en parallèle notamment une harmonisation
un petit peu des systèmes de tva des
accords aussi sur le lit ça ça s'est
fait en parallèle
et puis dans les accords de schengen
dans l'est dans la politique de schengen
on s'est mis aussi à ébaucher la
première coopération policière entre les
pays puisque si on laissait les
frontières ouvertes
il fallait aussi que et bien des
malfaiteurs puissent être
poursuivi par delà la frontière ou bien
que la poursuite puisse être confiée au
la police du pays suivant donc ça a été
le début de la coopération policière de
la lutte contre le trafic évidemment de
drogue
et toutes sortes de trafics qui pouvait
avoir lieu aux frontières donc une
meilleure coopération entre les services
alors on voit encore aujourd'hui que ces
sujets ne sont pas entièrement abouti 1
mais aujourd'hui on est dans un principe
de schengen est un acquis communautaire
c'est à dire que il est maintenant dans
l'est dans les traités et que tout pays
qui rentre dans l'union européenne
à terme doit mettre en oeuvre cette
politique et pouvoir
satisfaire à ces critères sauf deux pays
qui ont toujours dit qu'ils ne le
feraient pas la grande bretagne et
l'irlande ont ils ont un statut d' il
sait que la grande bretagne
évidemment avec le break 6 va nous
quitter mais l'irlande
du fait de son statut insulaire il lui
est plus facile aussi de vérifier les
entrées les sorties aux frontières
patrick le hyaric vous êtes l'auteur
d'un ouvrage paru récemment dont le
titre est le suivant et nos frères
pourtant pour une europe solidaire avec
les réfugiés sa sas a rejoint forcément
cette problématique de l'espace schengen
on va aujourd'hui vers un renforcement
des frontières ce sont les partisans de
la ligne dure ce dont on parlait déjà au
début de cet entretien
matteo salvini viktor orban qui gagnent
la bataille idéologique sur ce sujet là
encore comment vous rassurez vous ces
populations aussi qui parfois
soutiennent ces hommes politiques et qui
montrent leur inquiétude face à une
disparition de leur valeur des économies
qui pourraient être bousculées avec
l'arrivée de populations venues
d'ailleurs où d'autres continents
comment vous rassurez vous les gens pour
leur dire tout ça c'est faux on vous
ment mais d'abord il y a un devoir il ya
un devoir de solidarité
si on dit d'un côté que les valeurs de
l'union européenne c'est l'humanisme et
la solidarité
on ne peut pas laisser continuer à
laisser des gens mourir dans la mer
comme on le fait deuxièmement il y à une
question fondamentale qui est posée
quand est ce que l'union européenne va
s'engager dans un plan de long terme de
coopération avec le continent africain
avec le maghreb et le mas crèche de
telle sorte que ces populations vivent
dans la paix vive dans la sécurité et
puissent accéder à l'autosuffisance
alimentaire de l'europe investit
l'exemple ou facilitent par surya devoir
d'abord rien devoir de réparation
vis-à-vis de ses positions historiques
et d'autre part il faut créer les
conditions pour leur permettre de
trouver du développement par eux-mêmes
et en même temps il va falloir se battre
plus qu'on ne le fait contre le
réchauffement climatique parce que ce
qui va se passer avec le réchauffement
climatique poussera des migrations des
migrations sud sud vraisemblablement
mais une accélération du sud vers le
nord
on va conclure cette émission sur notre
comparaison européenne mensuel est en
lien avec une actualité très française
en ce moment puisque on se penche sur
les systèmes de retraite en europe
quel est l'âge légal chez nos voisins
comment s'articulent leur système les
précisions d'olivier jeunes ex
responsable du centre europe direct à
saint germain en laye on considère qu'il
existe principalement deux système
majoritaire il ya un premier système
conduit bismarckien parce qu'il a été
créé par le par le chancelier bismarck
et ce système s'il est davantage basé
sur la capitalisation auprès d'une
caisse de retraite spécifique à la
branche d'entreprise dans laquelle on
travaille le deuxième système et le
système qu'on dit beveridge bien et qui
est davantage basé sur un système de
répartition par l'état ou en fait c'est
que les citoyens cotisent pour une
caisse de retraite unique généralement à
l'état et l'état auprès s'occupe de
répartir la somme entre les différentes
personnes retraitées du pays
l'âge de la retraite est fixé par chaque
état alors
mais généralement on peut constater
plusieurs différents certains états ont
choisi de mettre en place un âge de
départ qui est fixe donc peu importe que
vous êtes un homme ou une femme
l'âge est exactement le même
généralement quand c'est comme ça on est
sur un âge de départ qui est aux
alentours entre 63 et 65 ans certains
états ont décidé comme la france d'avoir
un âge de départ différé en fonction du
sexe est en fait ce qu'on constate c'est
que en règle générale les femmes partent
à la retraite en moyenne à l'âge de 60
ans et les hommes partent à la retraite
en moyenne à l'âge de 65 ans alors après
il peut y avoir des ja voir des
différences entre les différents pays
par exemple si on prend le cas de
l'autriche les hommes partent à la
retraite à 65 ans tandis que les femmes
les femmes partent à la retraite à 60
ans tandis que si on prend le cas de la
bulgarie
les hommes partent à la retraite à 64
ans tandis que les femmes partent à la
retraite à 61 ans on constate que la
plupart des pays de l'union européenne
sont en train de retarder l'âge d'entrée
effective à la retraite
alors sachant que ce sont des ce sont
des réformes qui ne s'applique pas
immédiatement donc c'est progressif dans
le temps ce qu'on constate c'est que en
moyenne l'âge de la l'âge de la retraite
va varier entre 65 et 67 ans ça c'est
pour la majorité des pays et enfin on
constate qu'il ya une grande exception
qui est l'irlande qui elle a déplacé le
l'âge de la retraite à 68 ans merci
patrick le hyaric d'avoir participé à
cette émission d'avoir répondu à nos
questions vous êtes je rappelle
candidats aux élections européennes
du 26 mai prochain sur la liste du parti
communiste français député européen
depuis 2009 et directeur du journal
l'humanité merci aussi aux équipes
techniques du parlement européen pour la
réalisation prochain numéro du 7-8
europe fin avril pour une émission
consacrée aux élections plusieurs
intervenants et spécialistes seront en
plateau pour nous expliquer l'importance
de ce scrutin le rôle des parlementaires
par exemple merci à tous et à très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]